okay let's go ahead and get started good
good to see a nice robust turnout today
for a couple of our faculty every we we
try to try to entice the faculty into
presenting by doing these two firsts so
they only have to present half the time
and so today we are having two
presentations by our faculty Nicole
Weitz Kaufman Paul Gorman so I will be
quick Nicole is going to go first and I
think all of you know Nicole she's an
assistant professor in the department
she comes to us by way of Columbia
University I won't do the Stanford thing
like I did last week because it didn't
go over too well anyways she was a very
successful PhD student at Columbia and
we were thrilled to recruit her to ohsu
and she's going to talk about her
current project for those of you and I'm
sure there are people are watching
online if you would like to ask a
question send the tweet to at real OHS
suit now I'm just kidding to hashtag
demise comp dmic conf and either Shannon
or I will catch it and we'll ask it of
our speakers okay
okay is the microphone working can
everyone hear me fantastic so I'm going
to be presenting on research that's
based on an operational project that's
been going on for a while and also using
crezi for the first time ever so we'll
see how this goes so this is a
mixed-methods task analysis of the
implementation and validation of EHR
based clinical quality measures and
briefly who here is familiar with
clinical quality measures and is what
they are all right this is a brief
overview the process is surrounding cqm
clinical quality measure implementation
validation or complex time-consuming and
largely undefined so we collected issue
tracking data that we used during the
process of implementing and validating a
set of quality measures I'm going to go
into more detail on all of this and from
that issue tracking data we derived a an
implementation and validation process
and we identified major roadblocks and
bottlenecks so I'm going to give you an
overview of that and then I'm going to
finish up by providing some
recommendations for other people who are
working in this or related areas all
right so some background on clinical
quality measures the reason why we need
them is because they are necessary for
clinical quality improvement you can't
actually improve something unless you
know how you're doing and you need to be
able to measure that improvement if you
are trying to to change some of your
processes so cqms can be used in the
inpatient or outpatient ambulatory
setting and generally they are targeted
at measuring clinical processes clinical
outcomes or structures so institutional
structures mostly and outcomes are
difficult to measure so a lot of the
time we kind of take a step back and we
measure clinical processes instead so
basically are we delivering care the way
that we want to the way that we are
expected to
and clinical quality measures are
becoming more and more central in health
care and in informatics in 2009 with the
introduction of ara which included the
HITECH Act something called meaningful
uses was put forward and I'm guessing
everyone's familiar with that but
basically there's three stages of
Meaningful Use and it includes various
requirements of EHR is in order to be
certified and also healthcare
practitioners need to adopt EHRs that
have these capabilities and this also
includes promoting the use of electronic
health records for quality improvement
including through quality measures
quality measure reporting so this is
really something that is actually
codified in federal law at this point
and with each stage of Meaningful Use
there's more and more emphasis on it one
of my figures did not come through
that's cool okay so this is an example
of a clinical quality measure this is a
human readable one quality measures have
numerators and denominators and in this
case we are measuring the assessment of
left ventricular particular ejection
fraction or systolic heart function in
patients with heart failure so the
denominator for this is all patients who
are 18 and older and have a diagnosis of
heart failure and also who have had a
visit in the past year it doesn't say
that in this specification but it's
somewhere else in the technical details
which is one complication with these and
the numerator is that they need to have
either a quantitative qualitative
assessment of this ventricular ejection
fraction so the figure that you can't
see that's supposed to be right here is
a really nice Venn diagram some really
nice colors so even though this is
presented as a numerator over a
denominator what you're actually looking
at is the overlap between the
denominator and numerator the patients
who are in both and you divide that by
the overall denominator population and
you get a percentage of patients that
are meeting this quality measure
part of the complication with this is
generally when we're doing this with EHR
data we have limitations on the data
that we can access we also have
limitations on the quality of the data
so there are problems with completeness
there are problems with correctness
sometimes things are out of date so even
though in lvef may have been reviewed in
the past year it was actually entered
two years ago so we would miss that with
an automated system so they're all these
true positives but also unfortunately
lots of false negatives sometimes some
false positives so it's what we are
measuring is we're trying to get as
close as we can to the true performance
but it's difficult and part of this is
also because a lot of the data and the
HR is unstructured oh hey doesn't that
look nice all right so to to kind of
explain the role of informatics in this
so 4 / 4 quality measures there's
usually some kind of benchmark ideally
you want to reach one hundred percent
performance and then underneath that the
dashed line the black one represents
what the actual performances but we
can't even accurately assess that a lot
of the time what we have is the observed
results based on the data that we have
access to and with the power of
informatics we want to first get up to a
point where we are observing the truth
of the situation and once we can
accurately capture what's really going
on in terms of performance then we can
work on improving performance itself
does that make sense everyone knows what
a cqm is now okay so what's the problem
with us CQ on calculation through manual
chart review is incredibly
time-consuming it's unsustainable if you
want to have it going on longitudinally
so we need auto mated cqms there's been
some movement towards what are called
electronic or machine readable cqms but
they're not always available the the set
that we work with for this project or
human readable and they're still subject
to these same limitations
stemming from data quality and they're
not immediately computable you have to
map them and you have to have some kind
of institutional knowledge so overall
there's no good road map for how we do
this kind of implementation and right
now the entire process requires a
substantial amount of expertise and
manual development so what we need is a
roadmap how do we make this process more
streamlined how do we make sure that
what we are doing is comparable to what
other institutions are doing because
that's part of the goal here to know how
we're performing compared to other
people so in this project what we did
was we empirically derived a process for
cqm implementation and validation we
attempted to uncover common roadblocks
and bottlenecks and address them and
we're going to propose some solutions so
briefly our methods in setting this is
collaboration between the demise
informatics discovery lab and the night
cardiovascular institute we work with
nine heart failure measures that are set
forth by the American College of
Cardiology and we use an existing system
developed by David door the integrated
care coordination information system
also known as Isis these briefly are the
nine measures so we look at lvef
assessment in the inpatient and
outpatient setting symptom assessment
symptom management patient education the
use of certain medication classes beta
blockers and Asus and arbs and those are
actually a paired set of measures so we
did the development together for both of
them counseling regarding the
implantation of defibrillate the reveal
later device for patients were not
responding to medical therapy properly
and then the scheduling of a post
discharge appointment for patients in
the inpatient setting we realized during
the course of this project that there is
so much there were so many moving pieces
so much kind of cognitive overhead and
overload that we needed some way to
track what we were doing
so using the bridge site that is
available for 02 Deb Woodcock developed
an issue tracking database and we can do
this for each of the measures or for all
of the measures we create tasks we
assign tasks we identify problems you
can open and close a task you can set
priority and we weren't perfect about
tracking everything but basically
anything that was kind of an issue and
couldn't be taken care of immediately
ended up trapped here and then we used a
combination of qualitative and
quantitative analysis so even though
these data were totally operational we
basically downloaded them and analyze
them and the qualitative aspect of that
included doing open coding on all the
tasks and actually generating categories
of work involved in this process and
then three of us did consensus tagging
and assign each of the tasks to one of
those groups and then the quantitative
end it was fairly straightforward we
calculated the duration of each task and
I want to emphasize that this is not how
long it actually took to do the work
because some of these tasks ran
concurrently and also sometimes we would
open a task and then realize that we had
to do something else first so this is
just how long a task was open from
beginning to end and we refer to that as
task days and then we did some basic
temporal analyses and visualizations in
order to understand what we were
actually doing and what the process is
like so this is a brief summary of our
overall findings we identified seven
categories of work around this process
of implementation and validation versus
interpretation so you get your
specification your human readable
specification in this case what does it
actually mean how do we map this from
the concepts in the measure to the
concepts that are actually available to
us how do we identify the population of
interest then data exploration so maybe
there's some piece of data that we're
not aware of or that we haven't captured
yet and we need to go find it and bring
it into our system so that we can use it
for calculation system development and
debugging was work that
done on the back end so largely on Isis
in terms of etl of data elements and
basically creating the overall
processing infrastructure next was the
actual development and debugging of the
measures themselves which are all
written in sequel and then validation so
once we think the queries are working as
well as they possibly can we do a very
in-depth manual chart review old
standard based evaluation to see what
are we missing what are we capturing is
there anything else we can fix or if we
fixed everything we can what are what is
still getting this to this process then
after that we do synthesis and analysis
and that's a combination of kind of an
error analysis what are the most common
sources of mrs. in these queries what
are our recommendations in terms of
workflow or documentation changes and
also the development of a lot of really
great visualizations that take the
information from the c qm and make them
actionable for the providers and for kc
VI more broadly so that's the part where
we're actually really trying to improve
not just the calculation of the cqms but
the actual clinical performance with
that information and lastly informing
and updating stakeholders so the
delivery of this information to the
stakeholders and presentations or in
meetings and whoops
so these are some quick kind of summary
statistics about the different
categories of work so this is the number
the absolute number of each task by
measure and again six and seven or
paired those are the medication measures
and these are the overall task days and
again remember some of those run
concurrently so you can see six and
seven add a lot of tasks and it also
took a really long time there is a lot
of complexity there and then you've got
something like measure 9 which was the
scheduling of follow-up appointments
where there are not nearly as many tasks
but it still took a lot of time so there
are certain tasks involved that were
extremely time-consuming so I'm going to
dive into this data oh wait first I'm
going to do this so these are again the
seven categories and if you take kind of
a naive approach you might expect that
this is a largely linear process that
you start with interpretation you find
the data that you need you do a little
bit of iteration around system
development and measure development
until you get it right then you validate
you synthesize everything you deliver
your results and everything is great is
that actually what we find so the Gantt
charts represent the longitudinal work
that we did for this isn't all of the
measures but it's kind of a subset of
representative ones then at the bottom
we've got this category of all measures
this is not a combination of all of the
tasks these are tests that were
specifically assigned to all measures so
they were relevant for the entire
project instead of a specific measure
and some of these are kind of linear and
they follow that process we expected and
some of them are really not and I'm
going to step through some examples so
this one up here is the second measure
this is ovf assessment in the inpatient
setting this is a nice linear one so at
the top we did some interpretation at
the same time we were exploring the data
that we needed we were able to find it
because we already had those opf data
and then
that dark green line of the various dark
green lines is the system development
which took a while but it went fairly
according to plan we had to develop some
infrastructure to capture in patient
information which is different in how it
flows from the out patient information
and then we kind of proceeded nicely
through the measure development the
validation and the analysis and that was
great then this was the first measure we
did this is lvef in the outpatient
setting and this is the very first
measure we worked on and the big issue
with this one was we had a tremendous
amount of trouble identifying Casey VI
providers and patients there was no real
straightforward way to do this and the
provider list changes constantly so we
had to develop mechanisms for capturing
this for incorporating it into our
system and then how do we identify
patients based on that because often
patients are identified based on their
primary care provider for cqm
calculation and in this case we didn't
want to do that we wanted to identify
them based on if they had seen a case
ebi provider in which one so you can see
that was kind of an ongoing problem over
time and we got all the way to the point
of saying hey here are results then we
realized we had to go back and fix some
stuff this is the combined medication
measure for beta blockers and Asus and
arbs what happened with this one was we
were moving along we got to the point of
measure development we even got to the
point of validation and we realized that
we were missing some data elements we
had just been looking for medication
data and then we realized that there
were smart data elements in epic and
also some discharge orders where a
provider could say i prescribed this
medication or they could say this
patient is not should not be getting
this medication they should be excluded
from this measure all together so we
brought in those new ones and then we
had this incredibly complex logic that
we had to implement in sequel which is
basically saying if they meet this
criteria but not this one but what if
they also meet this one it took a while
so we started the validation redid
everything and then we had to do the
validation over again and it was a
complex validation because of all of
those elements
this was measure 9 the one that i
mentioned that had not that many tasks
but took a lot of time and that's
largely because we couldn't figure out
where to find the post discharge
appointments which seems like something
that's fairly straightforward but that
information lives in a special place in
epic and it was just very hard to track
down from the front end to where it
lived in the back end and then overall
across all the measures we just had lots
and lots of system work and this goes
back to that issue of the provider list
and attributing patients to the
appropriate providers and again a lot of
the time that's done based on the PCP or
the most recently seen provider and what
we realized is we wanted to do something
called multiple attribution so any
provider who has seen a patient during
the measurement period this patient kind
of goes on to their personal calculation
of how they are performing according to
these cqms and that involved is
developing a bunch of new infrastructure
everyone okay with that that's been is
that all right so this is at our
observed process it's still kind of
linear but every single point in the
process there is the possibility for
iteration when you're actually checking
the work that has been done is this
capturing the reality of the situation
can we fix this so at any point you
might you know you can get all the way
to validation and you say hey we're
missing some data and you go back up to
data validation so it's going to be very
time consuming but to some extent it's
unavoidable so here's the summary of our
issues for one thing our process is much
more iterative than expected and this is
actually a process for ec qm
implementation proposed by the American
Hospital Association and even though
those are supposed to be machine
readable they identify a lot of the same
problems in terms of data capture and
workflow redesign and is also very
iterative so it's interesting that we
kind of you know I realize these
diagrams will look very different but we
arrived at kind of the same conclusion
there's also the fact that system
development took a lot of time even with
a robot
existing platform so for people who
don't have that cqm engine they're
starting even further back than we are
and lastly this issue of data
exploration sometimes caused really
major derailments so here our
conclusions and recommendations so one
thing that we need to understand is the
difference between what we know we don't
know versus what we don't know we don't
know so with all of this iteration some
of its unavoidable because you there are
things that you're going to discover
along the way you need to be prepared to
discover them and that's okay it's
important but there are certain things
that we're iterating on that we really
should be able to front load into the
process those are the things that we
know we don't know if we know we don't
know something we should go and we
should know it before we start moving
forward so we know that we need to find
the data so this is something we should
front load as much as we can we know we
need to provide utility for the users so
this means we really need to understand
user needs as much as possible at the
start of the process so this is like
that issue multiple attribution that's
something we should have figured out to
begin with and going forward we will you
know try and front load that kind of
work but at the same time we need to be
open to this to the discovery of what we
don't know so unexpected problems and
new sources of information and that's
unavoidable and it's important and if
we're not open to that these measures
are not going to work as well as they
could so this is where we are now and we
decided to take some of this work and
actually make it actionable and useful
for our group and this is my last little
bit I realized I'm a bit over time so
these colors correspond to those seven
categories of work interpretation data
exploration system development very
development validation synthesis and
analysis actually those are six because
I left off the UM the reporting step
because that comes at the end of all of
this and then we also have these
different roles within our team and
that's one of our sprints that we have
this large collaborative team with
different skill sets so what we try to
do was outline this process in a
somewhat linear way with the
current responsibilities and breaking it
down into the individual components but
what you'll see is there are checks at
almost every single step of the way so
after someone just develops a query
logic and someone then starts
implementing the query there's a
different person who actually debugs the
query and make sure it's doing what it's
supposed to then someone checks the data
that are coming out of the query to make
sure that the data look the way they're
supposed to the validation similarly has
a number of steps and each of those
checks is an opportunity to make sure
we're doing things right and iterate if
we need to this has also made the team
hand off a lot smoother so when one
person finished their finishes their
assignment they know to create a task
for the next person and hand it off to
them so the dependencies have been
clarified and I wouldn't say that our
current work is going quickly but it is
going more smoothly and we're doing a
better job of front loading what we want
to and limiting that iteration to the
points that we really need to so oh look
at this indian one that is where we are
at this point again you have two
questions from the twitter them okay and
I'm going to read them to you and then
maybe short answers only cuz I know
we're strapped for time but the first
one is from Raja it says will machine
readable cqms help simplify the observed
implementation process and how to
systems like icc is adapt to xml cqms i
think those are too long to answer short
we can I can have your crafter apply on
the twittersphere no I can give us some
one quick answer I think it will help
but prior research indicates that the
machine readable ecq ms do not delete
negate this problem they still run into
a lot of the same issues with mapping
and needing to iterate and these things
they're not plug-and-play the hope is
that they would be but they're not oh
the XML yeah with the ICC is with Isis
I mean it again it means that things
will be somewhat more streamlined in
terms of implementation but there is
still going to be a certain degree where
of mapping going from the XML to what's
actually in the system with the adoption
of standards that really gets a lot
better but there's always going to be at
least some that you need to do actually
the other questions from Kate will tell
us that I'm sure you can't answer in 30
seconds but cqm is based on what gold
standard what are the gold standards for
clinical quality measures you can
probably talk for 30 minutes on so this
is actually this is kind of an
interesting point without diving too
much into it the real gold standard cqms
that are codified in meaningful use
standards are maintained by CMS and
there's also the National Quality
foundation that has these like really
formalized specifications for different
measures so these are actually from the
ACC and there's a lot of alignment
between these and some of the measures
that are maintained by the NQF these
were used to create some of the NQF
measures but there are certain
differences and casey bay i felt very
strongly that these acc measures did a
better job of capturing what was
meaningful for them in terms of their
care processes but ultimately they
should be based on some kind of evidence
oh yes yeah they are evidence-based and
if you read through any cqm
specification all right wrong
understanding of gold standard on that
there's a lot of information about why
why they're measuring what they are the
measurements are supposed to align to
clinical specific clinical practices
that are recommended specific clinical
guidelines
need to close the gap using
documentation templates to get the data
up in the front end that's actually a
really great question so one of our
partners in this project is an epic
analyst named anindita Bagchi who is as
already actually developed and started
piloting a template to capture this
information in a way that is going to
feed more directly into the measures but
also and this is really important is
making the information more actionable
for the providers because if we just ask
providers to document more into document
in a more structured way it's not useful
for them so the real trick is to say not
just how do we capture this information
but how do we help providers actually
take care of their patients better using
these data so that is going on that's
pretty cool okay our next speaker is dr.
Gorman who has been in this department a
long time along with myself and some
others and so however he's going to talk
about something new something that he
and I have have been wandering the
desert for seems like 40 years and we
just recently been let into the Promised
Land and I will let him tell the story
right beside actually bill you would
have made this slide in 1992 if you
could have I think he got on the
curriculum committee in in about ninety
two or something because he wanted to
get informatics into the curriculum and
it takes a while but we're starting to
get there so I want to talk about a new
role that I've been busying myself with
recently which has to do with getting
clinical informatics into the medical
school curriculum
first of all who am i and what do i do
some of you know me some of you don't
didn't I might be different from what
you do before so the main thing I spend
my time on right now is I'm a thread
director in the md curriculum which I'll
explain that figure in a minute the
second main thing I do nowadays is I'm
the assistant dean for rural medical
education so I get to go drive around
the state and try to make better rural
medical education third thing that I do
is I'm a coach for md students so we
have this coaching program to try and
help our medical students be their best
and the fourth thing I try to do is be a
medical informatics faculty that's not a
picture of our faculty that's actually a
picture of the study section at the
National Library of Medicine busy
thinking about informatics as they do so
who are you how many in this room are
health professionals of one sort or
another nurse doctor respiratory
therapist okay how many in this room are
computer scientists or engineers
primarily and these aren't mutually
exclusive categories of course are there
any library or information scientists in
the room okay social scientists
anthropology sociology social work
psychology and a paucity of social sites
any basic scientists anybody work at the
bench and is there anyone in the room
that's on management or organizational
scientist okay I had a nice figure from
y'all can more University Victoria that
kind of says those are all informatics
you had a nice way of depicting it but
so that's that's who you all are some of
you have been to medical school some of
you have not so we'll talk a little bit
about med md curriculum but first i want
to ask you if you had a pen and paper
with you we still use those artifacts
what do you want your doctor to know
about informatics you go in the office
you do you're waiting you get in there
you sit down the exam room in comes your
doctor what's the one thing you want to
be sure she knows about informatics
anybody Justin
how to get the information they need to
treat your problem Homer how to use the
electronic health record optimally how
to use the EMR optimally that's a tricky
word Gretchen how to get the latest
greatest and most up-to-date information
about my issue not only late not only
great but up to date anybody else is
that it is that a curriculum they want
to understand you want them to
understand what clinical informatics is
okay is that it that's a that's a
beginning agenda yet I want them to know
I'm more than my electronic medical
records chart so you want them to know
you're more than just an EMR template so
here's how some things doctors do they
build rapport with people they use up
almost every instant of spare time doing
something and these two doctors are
doing something while this one's I don't
know what they're doing checking the
stocks but doing some work all the time
and very often interacting with
technology a lot of it they engage and
educate their patients about their
disorders they work in multidisciplinary
teams using technology that looks like a
telecon sold they use diagnostic
technology of every description they try
to make medicine and healthcare be human
and they collaborate that's a surgeon
family doctor in a patient looks like a
good outcome is either happened or is
expected so how can we what do we want
those people to know so they can take
better care of us well you gave us some
answers and Bill Hurst and some others
on our faculty tried to answer this
question and came up with some
competencies for clinical informatics
and medical education which were
published two years ago and these are
the competencies that they came up with
fine search and apply knowledge based
information to patient care that sounds
like I was indeed Gretchen effectively
read and write from the EHR so some of
the things you talked about but some
others engage in quality measurements
selection and improvement that we just
heard about apply personalized and
precision medicine so they can figure
out if you've got a gene that makes you
metabolize that drug differently so
they'll prescribe a different drug or
prescribe it better so this is a pretty
good list and I'm not going to go into
all of it will be glad to send you a
copy of the paper puts a bunch of stuff
and that's categories there's actually a
bunch of competencies for each of those
but there's a problem this is Mark
Gosling's analogy the medical curriculum
is like penguins on an ice floe you can
only fit so many and once that ice floes
crowded each new penguin that gets on
pushes somebody off into the water where
the orcas are waiting now some of the
things we do in medicine try to get the
Penguins to hold hands so that they
won't fall off that is to say make
cognitive structures that make things
stick together but the truth is you
can't teach more stuff md students we
can march down to the CLS be and find
some if we ask them is there any room in
the cranium for more stuff they'll tell
you not a bit which brings us to the
next question what should we stop
teaching your doctor one of the things
your doctor knows that you would like
her not to know anymore so they can have
room for this informatics tough you've
got something Tim Krebs cycle one of my
favorite things in biochemistry I love
grub cycle actually I want my doctor to
have the enough knowledge of the kreb
cycle so if she truly needed to know
about it she could go real early look at
relearn it look it up quickly it's funny
that you bring up krebs cycle because
they change the name of the serum
glutamic acid oxalic acid transaminase
test sgot
to the aspartate transaminase test AST
and for me to remember whether it what
is a st and what's alt it's actually the
kreb cycle helps me rim that s'right
oxalic anyway it doesn't matter but it
helps me to remember so is there
anything else you don't want your doctor
to know because for example should we
teach them less Anatomy should we teach
them less which Anatomy do they not need
trick question they don't need to know
the insertion of every muscle in every
bone for the average position okay cell
biology statistics preventive medicine
how to interview and talk to people
nutrition I'm sure I'm confident I'm a
hundred percent certain that I can
within a miles walk find someone who
would tell you that we're not teaching
enough about each of these whether it's
the kreb cycle nutrition genetics
communicating with people ethics
professionalism so we got this zero sum
game problem it's not not a trivial
problem and we've dealt with it for
years and now we got more stuff to put
in there so the twentieth century
version of what doctors should learn was
there's these two big buckets there's
the basic science bucket and a lot of us
in the old curricula spend a year
learning this stuff and then there's the
clinical science bucket and a lot of us
spent the subsequent years learning this
stuff how to interview people and
communicate with them examine them
reason and so forth and now we're in a
different century and there's a third
big bucket and it we call it it's
starting to be called health system
sciences and it contains things like
there it is bill medical informatics
epidemiology health systems quality
safety those kinds of things and we're
really in a new world where of all the
stuff you used to have to learn in Tim's
right there's you gotta jettison
something
because there has to be room for new
things it's a different world physicians
for example need to understand in a much
deeper way than they ever have all of
the stuff that Nicole just talked about
what we're measuring how we're measuring
it why we're measuring it what those
measurements mean so here's what we've
been tested I looked at the United
States medical licensing exam study book
that students use when they cram for the
step 1 board exam this is the book and I
just kind of estimated the number of
pages for topics you can see there's
about thirty six pages of heart and
fifty pages of neurology there are six
pages of statistics and epi there's not
a word about safety and quality and
there's no informatics in there yes i'm
going to show you that it does so for
those that are on distance learning I
can't hear someone said they still have
nightmares from step one so here's the
newest version so the way they get this
is they talk to students who took the
exam and say what were the questions
about and they build this study guide
that's based on the past test not the
future test so the book the students
will buy this year has 44 pages of
cardiovascular and 38 of him and 32 of
renal nine pages of epi in stats a new
thing page and a half of safety and
quality so there's a new stuff fitting
in there if you look at the National
Board of Medical Examiner's content
outline for what they're building tests
of now this is the number of lines in
the outline devoted to each topic it's
kind of interesting to see that biostats
epi in the literature six percent are as
big as cardiology and renal think you'll
be happy systems safety in quality have
more lines of content in that outline
than the heart
and the kidney is a this is a sea change
this is huge and that's the testing
outline what they're planning to test
down in the future if you look at the
list of things that they think should be
incorporated clinical informatics health
care delivery systems economics policy
teamwork leadership and change agency
stuff that was nowhere near a medical
school classroom before and now it's a
big part of our content so we're going
to have to forget the kreb cycle or at
least most of it so at the School of
Medicine here we what time is it thank
you we revise our curriculum built the
new building built the new curriculum to
try and accommodate this sort of how do
we train the doctor of the future who
should not only be a skillful at
assessing and improving their own skills
but also able to adapt to new
discoveries and new technology and lead
a culture of change that creates a
continuously improving health system
that's what we're all hoping for we need
to start training physicians for that
this is a nice schematic of our new
curriculum let me walk you through it in
the preclinical years which start about
here we have seven blocks of integrated
clinical science that are kind of organ
system based they integrate basic and
clinical together ideally then in the
clinical year we by the way that's only
18 months so it went from 24 months to
18 then during the clinical years there
are seven core clinical experiences that
students do working doing actual direct
patient care with guidance and during
that core clinical time we actually
bring the students back for what are
called intercessions two-week periods
where they come back from the wards and
they revisit basic science and they
revisit Health System science and get
some concentrated deep dives into things
is that genetic stuff I learned about oh
yeah it's relevant i'm going to go
relearn it now and this is all very
flexible in individualized so it's much
more flexible than ever before
and then to make sure that certain
things get covered like anatomy you'd
like to be sure that is enough anatomy
in there that's a thread this yellow one
that is intended to be woven through the
curriculum through all parts of it and
so we have these big blocks and then we
have threads of anatomy and pharmacology
and so forth and the health system
sciences and informatics are some of
those threads and those are the threats
that I'm responsible for squeezing into
the curriculum and trying to produce
continuity so that's our new curriculum
as we were developing informatics
curriculum we used the competencies that
bill published about that the group of
faculty here developed and said by the
end of that preclinical time the day the
students step out onto the wards to
start doing practical work what
competencies what should they possess
and we thought they ought to be able to
do what Gretchen said and access the
latest knowledge they can learn they
ought to be good at protecting patient
health information they ought to be able
to access and use the EHR at a
rudimentary way as Homer said and we
also said they ought to be able to
engage the patients with the health
information technology not distance the
patients with the technology and it can
be either way I don't know if you've
been with a doctor where they were
paying more attention to computer than
you that's a very and you can use it
effectively we wanted to learn that and
then by graduation we want to be
competent users of health IT and data
not only to improve patients but also
populations and systems so those are our
milestones this is too small to read but
it's this the big picture of how we
envision threading this stuff on the
left in this column are the categories
of our competencies like access medical
knowledge and use decision support and
provide clinical data care with
telemedicine and across the columns at
the top are the major blocks of
curriculum preclinical milestone and
then the clinical year
and one of the things we reason was that
some parts of the curriculum some of our
goals and objectives would be better met
in the preclinical classroom phase but
other things we thought would be better
learned later in the clinical phase
quality improvement for example you kind
of need some clinical experience even
know what they're talking about when
they say let's make sure the left
ventricular ejection fraction is
documented in every progress note and so
students can understand why it might or
might not be there so we came up with
this big framework and started to
develop specific goals for each for how
to integrate these concepts into the
curriculum a couple of strategies the
challenge is how to fit this stuff in
there one of our strategies was to try
to tailor the content to the weekly
curriculum content so if this week
they're learning about kidneys and the
nephron we'll try to find a way to make
our informatics content match or
complement or help them learn that so
the informatics seems to be a part of it
the second thing we we did was we tried
we made a lot of what we call clinical
pearls so in medicine teaching medicine
there's this pearl of wisdom that
traditionally you know you would learn
from the Masters this little clinical
pearl a little nugget of valuable
information so we thought let's make
some informatics pearls and each week
we'll give them five minutes ten minutes
of some trick or useful way to use the
EHR or the technology we call those
clinical informatics pearls and we meant
for them to help them get the
information they needed to study that
week so if this week they're going to
talk about anemia then we wanted to show
them in the EHR how to get to look at
the blood counts and see them and see
them arrayed in a graph for example and
the idea there was to build skills in
small relevant increments um the third
strategy was what Howard Silverman from
Arizona told me to try which is cotton
ball and water glass the idea here is if
you have a glass
water it holds a certain out of water if
you put a cotton ball in there first you
can put almost the same amount of water
but now the cotton balls there so how do
we get the informatics integrated so
completely that no one notices that we
displace some of the water and that's
deeply embedded in the clinical content
we also had traditional didactic
sessions we have skills labs and some
assessments and some supplemental
enrichment week sessions for part of the
class here's an example of a pearl in
this particular week the patient the
students are presented with the case of
a patient and doctor Gosselin the
director of the Foundation's curriculum
gives them a little intro to it and with
that there's a clinical informatics
pearl that says if you want to read
about if you want to learn a particular
thing or do a particular task here we
have one of our faculty with a little
short video saying here's how you do
this here's how I do this to give them
little tips so that was the idea behind
the pearls that's sideways I've had
almost everything go wrong in a
presentation I had a better one in you I
had a graphic that didn't show if it was
the whole slide this was in London at
med info and the only thing on the slide
was p less than point 05 there's girls
there so i don't know what it was but it
was significant anyway in this
particular case that says serologic
tests of rheumatology so Leslie kale
wanted to teach the students how to use
blood tests for things like lupus and
rheumatoid arthritis and I wanted to
teach them base theorem and receiver
operating characteristics and I'm pretty
sure no one will show up or stay away if
they're at a lecture on base theorem and
receiver operating characteristics so
instead the two of us co-taught session
where she was able to make the point she
wanted about DNA and I was able to slip
in a little positive predictive value
stuff and that's the sort of cotton ball
in the class matter which takes a lot of
time and work to make it happen status
report some things are working some
things
or not if you live in Portland and
you've been driving across the one of
the other bridges you notice somewhere
near here this thing sticking up in the
middle of river it wasn't clear what
that thing was but a few months later
there was another thing sticking up into
the river it looked kind of similar and
over time it became evident that they
were building a bridge and now we have
this gorgeous Tilikum bridge down there
and that's how we're building the
informatics curriculum we're putting
pieces in one at a time we're probably
about there maybe we're there but it's a
price it's a work in progress challenges
number one the variable background of
students using Instagram is not computer
savvy so we had sessions we did a
session to look at quality data and we
had them all open to step up in an Excel
spreadsheet and a lot of people have
never put a formula into an Excel
spreadsheet so some of the things we
assume they'd be able to do they have no
idea second students are deer in the
headlights of step 1 so step one is the
board exam they have to take it is
perceived to be and it's a real
perception the determinant of one's
future you literally toss out whole
possibilities for careers based on that
score so they're very focused on step
one and if it's not on step one then why
are you talking to me about it is the
way there they think and its realistic
for them to think that way so if
informatics isn't on step one then why
are we teaching it what they don't know
is it's going to be on step one it just
hasn't been in the past third it isn't
it doesn't seem too many that these
health system sciences are relevant I
think for students they're getting
stories from their second years and
third years and fourth years and
residents we tell them all you don't
need to know that stuff I never learned
that stuff and their faculty telling the
same thing I trained in the 70s they
need that stuff and there may be their
vision of what
dr. is doesn't include looking at
population data or quality improvement
projects and also I think we have some
backward facing faculty it's very hard
and I'm one of them you know I've spent
years developing this wonderful lecture
that I do and now they tell me well no
we got to get rid of that and do this
other stuff and and so it's a very
difficult change process there's the
bricks or mortar argument or difficulty
Anatomy is a block of curriculum you can
recognize it we're taking an Anatomy
course now there's a textbook
stethoscope isn't there's no stethoscope
class there's no stethoscope block but
we teach stethoscope everywhere and so
the question a question arises should
you have a block of stuff or should you
try to insert stuff everywhere so it's
all most people don't even know they're
learning it there's a lot of technical
issues we've we have a master she's
sitting right over here at helping us
use epic to teach students how to use
epic but there's a lot of limitations
because for I think I know there's any
EMR that was built with a student in the
workflow model and so getting setting
the EMR to accommodate students as a
challenge and then there's very few
faculty who have the breadth and the
depth and the time to teach this stuff
so often we have to rely on faculty you
may not be as familiar with the concepts
to teach the stuff that we need to teach
those are some of the challenges and
I've been amount of time questions
thoughts comments
through time for questions yeah cool I
talk fast how is this translated into
their residency going forward beyond the
four years of medical school I'm
thinking about information and how they
translated your residency well they'll
almost certainly do their residency
somewhere else and there's good news and
there's bad news I think for me the goal
the whole I mean the ideal is our
students are more attractive to
residences because we train them better
and so if we've done a good job than
residents would say yes send those
students because one of the things we're
hearing from residences everyone's
hearing from residences is the students
are not ready they're showing up and
different residents that are developing
boot camps now because students show up
and don't know how to for example write
orders with the computer and part of
that is because they're not allowed to
write computer and so they don't learn
it so one of our goals is to get them
more residency ready on the other hand
it's almost certain that they'll face
different technologies and different
workflows when they get there so some of
what we learnt what we want to teach
them I don't know will transmit i'll
just add an adjunct to that that the
residency training here at ohsu has
shifted to where they receive a basic
four to eight hour epic instruction on
our epic but then they have an optional
second session that is led by the chief
residents in certain departments and
it's tailored specifically to what they
need to know in our each EHR to hit the
ground right one of our masters students
a few years ago maybe I noticed that
surgery residents were learning to use
five different EMRs because they were
roading to rotate into five different
places and she was struck by the fact
that every place had completely
different requirements about how much
training they needed from like two weeks
to two minutes and so this sort of how
are they learning this stuff was a real
interesting question to her into pieces
yeah in some residency programs
including the ohsu family medicine
residency they've decided it actually
can't be a zero-sum game and they've
added an extra year they've made it from
three year residency to a fourth year
mandatory residency the fourth year
includes health science health services
science informatics population health
quality improvement patient safety
curriculum and project work yeah you
give me a rough idea just really
ballpark how much time is it taking to
implement the medical informatics thread
relative to how far you've gotten in it
I think that to be out what I can tell
you this useful is a mistake I made was
trying to integrate too much and it's
actually Howard sillerman told me this I
don't know why even listen to him back
but try I had this vision of integration
it's going to be so seamless and
wonderful and connected and relevant but
a that makes it disconnected from the
point of view informatics so as I
rethink it it's better to plan a
coherent structure first this then this
then this and make it more evident to
the students that that's what they're
learning and sacrifice a little bit of
innovation the other thing is the
integration is wonderful when it happens
but it's really hard you know most
faculty the person talking at nine has
not seen the slides of the person
talking at ten and so it's very very
difficult to get everybody even meet and
then come up with good stuff when they
do they come up with great stuff like
one of my favorites is outbreak so the
next block is GI they're going to get a
couple of pearls that teach them how to
order a blood test like a stool culture
and how to check on a test they're going
to get a little bit of epidemiology
about outbreak investigation and they're
not going to know why and then they're
going to get presented with a person who
has diarrhea and are going to be told to
order of culture and a couple days later
than we told check their cultures and
and they're going to have all different
patients but all the patients they have
are going to have an e coli infection
which creates an outbreak investigation
so one of the things where we kind of
bunch of us got together we figure out
how could we make
the EPI pieces and informatics pieces
and the GI pieces and the infection
control pieces fit together and then
that outbreak investigation talks about
systems based approaches to controlling
infection in hospital so that it's
golden when it happens but it's a lot of
work okay the first one is from Damien
it says what are the top five
informatics topics that were added to
the curriculum damia barboza what should
be listening in from Salt Lake City
Damien Barbosa from Argentina and now
from Salt Lake so the top five that were
added i would say information literacy
accessing acquiring appraising
information that's number one number two
there's a lot of EHR content but it's
spread out so that they don't know
they're getting it number three would
actually be a precision medicine there's
some really good sessions on precision
medicine and genetics number four would
be quality improvement and I don't know
what number five is yes
yeah yeah what well so that gets into
the difference between training and
education there are two parts of the two
parts to my answer to that question what
the question for those that in distance
streaming are was what are the chances
that by the time current students
graduate there will be some new
technology that they have to learn and
the answer is twofold one is that's why
we need to educate not trained which is
to say training them to use epic is a
dead end teaching them educating them
about using hrs and trying to find those
abstract translatable skills is a much
more useful thing and I think that's
what we're trying to do this part two of
that is though is what are the chances
there'll be a new technology you know if
you'd asked me that the day before the
web I said ah things will be the same
don't think don't worry about it so
there's want one more Twitter question
actually there's some yeah from Kristin
Stephens one of our MD PhD students has
there been success with team talk
clinician plus subject area expert
lectures has the been success with team
talk with teen talk clinician plus
subject there are expert lectures I
think she oh yeah team-taught
team-taught clinician club subject area
so Leslie kale and I doing rheumatology
there's another good one Dennis coupe of
pharma co pharmacology and physiology
was teaching a session on
pharmacogenomics and sort of differences
in genetic differences in metabolism of
drugs and he divided the students into
groups each of whom worked on a
different class of drugs and I was in
the room to add some kind of the
clinical content so i think it's it's
very possible and when it happens it
could be very successful but i think
every kind of multidisciplinary work
takes a lot of work just to know what
the other guys talking about i was
working on a team on a research project
and we had a word we the computer
science and i were using a particular
word and it took us a year to discover
we meant something different by that
word and i think that's a challenge it
takes a while to get to we're on the
same page but it definitely works
yeah yes sir it's not so much the
technology is understanding the systems
of healthcare as we move into the future
because that's what's rapidly changing
when you get talked about population
health quality and safety and now
value-based income so physicians now as
we go into 2020 will not be paid on a
fee-for-service they're going to be paid
on quality outcomes and how good they
are protecting the patient safety
improving the quality readmission rates
were already penalized for readmission
rates if they're higher than a certain
percent of less than 30 days all these
type of things and that's that's more
system based so we're in a COC seals
with all population-based and that's
where things are going and so technology
and informatics is going to help with
that but the training has to be in that
area of systems I think yep absolutely
assistance is that we all right well
thank you everybody been fun what are
the chances we'll all be carrying a
device that we can't live without and
look at a thousand times a day health
and systems systems universally what if
someone good luck with that wayward
medical school that someday you'd be
carrying around a device that gives you
access to all the world's knowledge and
you would use it to look at pictures of
cats and partner with strangers you
don't know